[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Antoine Maquet je
suis soigneur animalier ici à Toir
depuis 7 ans maintenant et je suis là
aujourd'hui pour vous présenter les
dernières naissances de Lyon de lyonce
plus précisément du coup deux petites
femelles qui s'appellent Sana et
[Musique]
Sarabi
les Lions se reproduisent très bien en
captivité il y a beaucoup de parcs à
travers la France et l'Europe en général
qui ont des lions et qui les
reproduisent donc c'est des animaux qui
se reproduisent très bien en captivité
mais c'est toujours une bonne nouvelle
d'avoir des naissances dans un parc
zoologique parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui les parcs
zoologiques vont travailler ensemble
main dans la la main en France en Europe
même à travers le monde pour justement
participer à la conservation à la
préservation des espèces menacées et le
lion d'Afrique celui qui nous concerne
aujourd'hui il est classé vulnérable sur
la liste rouge de l'UCN donc c'est une
position qui est vraiment pas
confortable pour lui en Afrique dans ses
pays d'origine il va subir beaucoup de
pression notamment bien sûr
principalement à cause de l'homme il va
être chassé tué braconné et donc avoir
des naissances en parc zoologique ça va
participer justement à préserver cette
espèce qu'on pourra éventuellement un
jour
[Musique]
réintroduire tout est un peu possible
pour l'instant c'est sûr qu'on va les
garder ici à toiri avec leurs maman ils
ont besoin d'elles ils vont elles vont
probablement grandir ici et puis
éventuellement un jour elles partiront
vers un autre parc zoologique parce que
les animaux sauvages qu'on a ici à Toir
en fait ne nous appartiennent pas
vraiment ils font partie d'un programme
d'élevage européen qu'on va gérer comme
son nom l'indique au niveau européen et
là il y a une personne qui va décider ID
des arrivées et des départs des animaux
pour assurer un patrimoine génétique le
plus intéressant possible pour l'espèce
donc ces deux femelles pourront
éventuellement partir vers un autre malâ
reproducteur pour comme je vous le
disais assurer un brassage génétique
[Musique]
intéressant les petits alors ils vont
être un petit peu plus actifs que les
parents hein c'est bien connu les bébés
ils vont jouer ils vont découvrir la vie
ils vont tourner dans le grand enclos
qu'ils ont ici à disposition à toiri et
puis rapidement ils vont grandir et ils
vont adopter le même rythme que que
leurs parents pour l'instant ils têtent
et puis petit à petit il vont se mettre
à grignoter un peu la ration de leur
maman jusque un moment donné on va
vraiment leur distribuer une vraie
ration rien que pour
[Musique]
eux voilà je vous ai présenté les deux
dernières naissances ici à toiri les
deux petites lyones Sana et Sarabi
hésitez pas à venir les voir et les
observer ici chez nous